[MUSIC]
AGREAT WEAR LABORATORY s edge
ANTIKA state Oh is 9 s
this
1 POWER
THIS PANTS BE LADY ARE YOU CHILDREN
r
tee
Martin Franz to do
[music]
Sontei edition 2 s 2 May
everything be with the shop fashion
Force I'm in the
car
Mr. Ike peace chiffon lawn
I went to do this and my family's ancestors have a lot of these people
That sword always supports each other with all their strength That's
yours Aaaahhh
[music]
Huh,
you've been guided by the Force ever since you were born
I've been waiting for this moment
[music
]-like darkness and the first earth
[music] I
can feel the darkness Because we
can become a family properly ah ah
Respectfully big huh
[music]